well joy reid has defamed a lot of
people during her time at msnbc now
she's targeted somebody who's going to
fight back jack brewer is a former nfl
player and a philanthropist he's
threatening to sue joy reid over a tweet
she said about sent about an event
featuring the governor of florida ron
desantis reid claimed that a picture of
young african-american boys at that
event was quote tantamount to child
abuse
and brewer says the boys in that photo
were students he was mentoring and they
knew exactly what they were doing we
thought we'd ask him about it jack
brewer was the founder of the jack
brewer foundation and we're happy to
have him joining us tonight mr brewer
thanks so much for coming on so child
abuse
what i mean that's a very heavy charge
it really is first off tucker i'm a man
of god and those kids that you see are
children of god and that's what
principles that we stand on at the jack
brewer foundation particularly are our
hero kids and say i don't believe that
joy really understood who she was
dealing with and the anointing that's on
our lives god called us right now to
face this crt these same kids the
majority that you see in that picture
that are with me are fatherless kids
kids that come to our center each and
every day to learn reading the math
proficiency when they go to public
schools and the teachers tell them that
if they make a 50 or 60 that it's okay
because they're black kids we fight
against that we teach our kids that in
america everybody can win everybody can
reach and achieve the goals that they
set forth and so we are patriots and i
don't think that people like joy reid
are used to seeing african-american
young boys that are fatherless that love
this country and understand really uh
what their potential is and that's what
we teach and that's what we show and so
i don't hate joy reid i dislike her
comments but i pray for her because she
should be on our side if she really
cares that america is the most
fatherless nation in the cun in the
world the entire world on the planet
america has more followers kids she
should be fighting on my side over here
i work and serve these children each and
every day they eat my food at my house
they sleep on my couch when they need
some new shoes i buy them when they need
new clothes i buy them and so for her to
come at me like that and to accuse me of
child abuse when i've poured my entire
life heart and soul into going out and
serving the most underserved kids in our
nation i have a real problem with that
she is going to have to apologize i want
msnbc to apologize or otherwise i'm
going to have to pursue uh my legal um
strategy that my lawyers are putting
together
i gotta a and thank you because that's
too much of all the things you could be
mad about
in this world and there are a lot to be
mad about i would say right now she's
mad because little kids without dads are
getting help from somebody like why do
you think that made her so angry
because she's not used to say it doesn't
fit her uh perspective and the less
perspective in this woke agenda that's
taken over this country the heart and
soul the most voiceless kids in our
country right now are young followers
african-american boys who are locked up
too much in our prisons who are
overlooked and no one really speaks for
them well i got a group of black boys
that'll tell you right now that they
give it all they got and we sit on god's
principles we put the word of god we
pray over our kids each and every day
and we know the great men they're going
to become she's not used to hearing that
that's not what the left wants to tell
you we are not oppressed we are not
victims right we love everybody we love
our god but we love our neighbor as
ourselves and i think she needs to do
some deep soul searching and everybody
on the left right now that is pushing
this victimization upon young black kids
who really at the end of the day are the
heartbeat of our nation when we uplift
our poor black voiceless kids this
nation is going to change tucker i'm
telling you it is and i believe it and
i'll stand on that all day
amen it seems like a really positive
thing she's a cynical person and i hope
you get an apology you deserve one mr
brewer thank you for joining us tonight
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight